awesome
um I'm surprised to see people here the
people at the front desk were a little
surprised to see me here so I don't know
how to take that
um but we'll we'll kick it off anyway
um so thanks heaps for coming along
um I do a lot of tech presentations as
part of work so when I come to
conferences like this I like to do
something a little bit different
um and the last few years I've been
looking at kind of areas outside of tech
where I think we can kind of learn from
like so other Industries or other areas
and a few years back before all this
coveted Shenanigans
um I did a talk on what's called
cognitive biases from psychology
and during that talk I use an example of
a plane crash to explain something
called fixation bias where you get so
focused on something that you kind of
forget everything else
and the feedback I got from that talk
was that the people wanted to hear more
stories about plane crashes so here we
are an entire talk about plane crashes
um I listened to feedback so I want to
emphasize that today my goal isn't to
make you scared of flying and it isn't
as scary it's quite the opposite and
commercial air travel is incredibly safe
and I think that there's a whole lot
that we can learn from them and the
lessons that they've learned over the
years and but a bit of a warning I am
going to be sharing real stories real
plane crashes that are pretty close to
home
um so if you are a nervous flyer this
may not be the talk for you
um otherwise we'll kick on
so I want to start with the story of
United Airlines flight 173 so this was a
cross-country flight from New York to
Portland with a stop over in Denver and
on the 28th of December 1978 the plane
operating the flight shown here was a
1960s era McDonald Douglas dc-8 um so
that's a four engine narrow body
aircraft uh capable of carrying more
than 250 passengers
for the evening lag from Portland to den
or from Denver to Portland sorry it's uh
that 179 passengers and tank crew
boarded the plane
the pilot in command was Captain McBroom
one of United's most experienced
captains along with the most much less
experienced flight uh first officer and
a flight engineer named Forrest
Mendenhall
the flight proceeded normally until
Final Approach into Portland just after
5 PM local time
coming in from the the southeast uh the
crew ran through the approach checklist
which included lowering the landing gear
um but there was a problem part of the
mechanism that retracts the right
lightning gear was corroded
and when the crew lowered the gear the
corroded part kind of broke away
allowing the gear to drop into place
that took the whole plane
um in the cockpit the light that should
show that the landing gear was down and
locked failed to illuminate that was
because the force of the the landing
gear dropping had actually cut the
circuit to the indicator light and but
despite this the light or the the
landing gear was actually down and
locked but the crew had no way of really
knowing this
so the captain advised air traffic
control that they had a problem with
their landing gear and needed to hold
until it was resolved the controller
directed them into a holding pattern
basically flying a loop or bog laps just
away from the airport and to give them
some time to to fix the issue
to confirm if the gear was down the
flight engineer went back into the cabin
with the flashlight to check if there
was a little Rod which kind of popped up
on the wing when the landing gear is
down and locked on this type of aircraft
um so looking through a passenger's
window I'd imagine that passenger was
like yeah what the hell
um with with a flashlight
um he thought he could see the rod but
couldn't 100 tell whether or not it was
there
so this kind of only reinforced the the
captain's kind of concerned that the
right landing gear wasn't down and
wasn't locked and that it might collapse
on Landing
so they ran some more checks but they
were inclusive about 30 minutes into the
holding pattern
um he called up to leave flight
attendant and asked him to prepare the
cabin for an emergency landing
at 5 47 so about 47 minutes into the
holding pattern the first officer asked
the flight engineer how much fuel do we
have left and Manuel Hall replied five
thousand pounds so that's nothing for an
aircraft and it should have been a clear
sign to the captain that they needed to
get out of this holding pattern and get
onto the ground as quickly as possible
and but the captain didn't seem to take
the hint and he said I reckon another 15
minutes
and apparently still trying to look for
that one little test that we're telling
with 100 certainly that the landing gear
was down unlocked and the flight
engineer wasn't happy with this not
surprisingly and basically said not
enough 15 minutes is going to run us
real low on fuel here basically top
trying to tell Captain Mike Broome that
they were running out of fuel without
actually telling them they were running
out of fuel
at 5 54 coming up on another circuit on
that Loop um
the captain McBroom sent Mendenhall back
into the cabin to check whether the
pastures and crew were ready for the
emergency landing so this was right
about the time where I should have been
leaving the loop and going into to land
um but seemingly kind of oblivious to
what was going on he started another
loop
at 606 pm and so an hour and six minutes
into the into the holding pattern with
the plane still now at this point
heading away from the airport
um
the flight attendant came into the cabin
and formed the the uh the pilots that
they were ready the cabin was ready
um Mike room finally acknowledged that
they were ready to land and
um turned back towards the airport
at that exact moment the number four
engine started rolling back as its fuel
tank ran dry the first officer said we
are going to lose an engine macroom
asked why and the first officer applied
fuel in what I imagined was a quite
sarcastic tone and the they rushed to
open the cross feed valve so these were
valves that were left fuel flow from
engines that don't have anything in it
to ones that do and but this proved to
be pretty useless as all of the the fuel
tanks were running dry at that point
um number four at that point number four
engine flame diet followed Moments Later
by number three so those are the two
outer ones on the wings and 19
kilometers short of the runway engines
one or two ran out of fuel and they both
flamed out as well
with less than about two minutes before
the plane would hit the ground the crew
had to find some place to land in a very
kind of heavily forested suburb they
thought they spotted a dark spot ahead
and aimed towards it as best they could
unfortunately what they were looking at
was in a field it was a section of
neighborhood where several houses just
happened not to have any light on
the DCA just barely avoided a
multi-story apartment Tower and the
plane plowed through trees before the
left wing struck a house ripping the
wing off and leveling the building the
rest of the plane slid across the street
bringing down power lines before
striking another house and demolishing
it
the cockpit and first class at
disintegrated while the rest of the
fuselage came to a halt
at the front of the airplane the lead
flight attendant was dead along with the
flight engineer Mendenhall and eight
passengers but Captain McBroom survived
along with the first officer and 171
passengers who at this point were now
making their way out of the the fuselage
I'm very confused into into the
surrounding suburb
incredibly low despite the fact that the
plane had totally destroyed two houses
both were unoccupied and nobody on the
ground was hurt
once they're just cleared though the
industry faced a hard question how had
an experienced crew flying a perfectly
serviceable airplane run out of fuel and
crashed killing 10 people
and the answer would really kind of
change Aviation forever
the national Transportation safety board
and TSB in the U.S investigate all the
crashes in the US they found that the
the crew especially Captain Mike Broome
had lost his sense of the passenger time
and any sense of how much fuel it had on
board
and the hints from the co-pilots that
they were running low
um were automatically tuned out and the
first officer and the flight engineer
really failed to assert themselves and
instead kept waiting for my Broome to
kind of realize what they were what they
were hinting at and see the writing on
the wall
that show that their respect for
mcboom's authority was was really
getting in the way of safe flight
especially from Mendenhall who was
keenly aware of the situation but kept
doing whatever Mike room told them to do
like going back into the cabin even
though he knew they were running out of
fuel
in its final report on the crash of
Flight 173 the NTSB forcefully
recommended the introduction of what's
now called crew resource management or
CRM so yay another CRM into every
Airline cockpit
CRM training though would specifically
teach captains to number one delegate
responsibilities effectively ensuring
that you know someone was always flying
the plane and that people weren't
overloaded with responsibilities
and number two to communicate clearly
and directly asking fellow crew members
for input
it would also teach first and second
officers to speak up when concerned and
even introducing things like formulaic
openers to use when they felt there was
a problem so they could bring it to the
captain
and they'd also be taught that sometimes
the captain doesn't always know better
and that when the safety of the flight
is on the line that they should actually
just take over
and United Airlines was the first to
adopt CRM training and all other major
U.S airlines followed quite quickly
after
today CRM is used in every Airline
around the world um and even in other
high-stakes professions like emergency
medical care and firefighting its impact
in saved lives is incalculable um in
fact it's widely regarded as the single
most significant factor in the dramatic
Improvement of Aviation safety in the
last 50 years
based on passenger deaths per kilometer
and flying in 2021 was about 32 times
safer than it was in 1970.
and because pilot error is the the
single largest uh cause of accidents and
much of that Improvement can be credited
to CRM
for for most of us in it we aren't
working on critical systems like this
where our lives are on the line
um but there is a lot that I think we
can learn from resource management
understanding how you can communicate as
a team and how you communicate with
other teams I think is one of the most
important factors of the success of most
projects and I think that most of us
would agree that the way a lot of
companies organize and manage technical
teams can be a little disappointing at
times
when I first started out I I assume
there'd be kind of structured processes
and and patterns like we've learned
about at University and it was a little
bit shocking to to kind of realize that
managers were basically just winging it
most of the time and you know didn't
really know what they were doing
and I think a lack of a structured
process is why we've seen things
um like people copying the Spotify model
which is a personal pet peeve
um and monstrosities like safe you know
the scaled agile framework I think we're
kind of longing for that one true way of
doing things
um
but yeah um
so what I think a lot of companies now
though are starting to realize is that
you can't just copy and paste
organizational design and there are too
many variables involved and for us it's
a little bit more complicated than the
organizational Design Within a cockpit
so I've been really excited with the the
momentum that's kind of growing around
this in the last few years um and I
think there's a few resources that can
really help to to get you started
looking at this
um Team topologies uh really brought
together a lot of the concepts that that
have been gaining traction and combined
it with some real practical kind of
advice it proposes things like we
restrict team responsibilities to match
the the cognitive load so similar to
what I talked about in CRM absolutely we
don't overburden the team with more kind
of tasks than they could take on
collectively
and it also details topologies or
structures for your teams for for a
specific kind of situational context
within your organization
Wordly mapping is a technique to help
visually map your strategy that this was
created by Simon wardley and you can use
it to collectively design and
communicate where you're going like
Pilots do at Maps they're a very very
important thing for them
um
most Airlines have rules around pairing
less experienced people together and I
think Dynamic reteaming is something
that we can use to do something similar
it helps us to build kind of learning
organizations and nurture and develop
people within teams
and all of these new approaches combine
extremely well with Concepts like domain
driven design
and I really feel like with the
combination of these we're starting to
develop the tools necessary to to design
modern kind of Technology teams
purposely and effectively and coming
close to defining our own kind of
version of crew resource management
um so Suzanne Kaiser beat me to the
punch and uh put together a great talk
on this combining all these things I
actually did this one at DDD France it's
available on YouTube if you want to have
a watch I'd highly recommend it
um and those books as well if you
haven't read those they are great
going back to Captain Mike Bruno so all
of the mistakes that he made were kind
of symptomatic of a deeper underlying
problem in the aviation industry it
wasn't the first time something like
this has happened and he still took the
fall for the crash and was forced to
retire immediately afterwards and he
actually lost his pilot's license and
never flew again
and mcgroom himself seemed to waver
between kind of blaming himself and
blaming the system
um although you know he clearly kind of
thought both about fault
and most people in the industry though
kind of only really felt pity for them
they didn't feel angry and he'd fall and
pray to something that any of us really
could
and the attitude towards a portioning
blame has changed in the airline
industry since it's matured as it's
matured since the 70s and which we will
see in my next example
so on the 1st of June 2009 this aircraft
uh an Airbus A330 flying as Air France
flight 447 if you remember that one and
took off from Rio de Janeiro to Paris
it proceeded normally for about three
and a half hours but which point it
entered a radar Dead Zone in the middle
of the Atlantic where neither the
controllers in Brazil or the controllers
in Senegal over on the other side of the
Atlantic
um could see a plane on their screens
at about 1 55 am UTC uh Captain Mark
Dubois traded places with the relief
co-pilot and David Robert and Robert
flew alongside co-pilot Cedric Pierce
bonnen for another 15 minutes before
things started to go wrong
a large thunderstorm appeared in the
plane's flight path and the pilots
decided to fly through it because they
couldn't climb high enough to go over
the top of it and normally Pilots will
will try and fly around thunderstorms
and why they didn't is is still unknown
to this day
um although it was likely to to put the
plane in any serious danger the
thunderstorm did cause one minor issue
ice crystals formed in a part of the
plane called the pivot tubes
so pivot tubes are on the tiny little
tubes on the outside of the aircraft
that measure air speed as it rushes into
them and because they were blocked it
began feeding incorrect information into
the autopilot
this then switched the autopilot into a
state of the flight controls into a
state that's called alternate law so in
Ultimate law the autopilot functions
that rely on that AirSpeed and turn off
and that also turned off the anti-stall
capability
so stars are what happens when there's
not enough kind of airflow going over
the wing of an airplane so it can
produce enough lift and it's typically
kind of caused what's called a high
angle of attack where the plane is kind
of pointing up kind of too high
and the pilots though have been briefed
on what to do with the pivot tubes
became blocked that the normal procedure
was just to keep the aircraft level
until it unlocked and it would usually
just take a couple of minutes
and but as the autopilot disconnect
warning sounded the pilots didn't take
those steps and and what followed was it
like really a complete breakdown of crew
resource management
um first officer born and announced that
that he had control but instead of
holding the planes Daddy he started
panicked and really started to pull back
on the control stick that sent the plane
into a climb of over 7000 feet per
minute
now a variety of things might have
contributed to why why he did this um
Pilots had been kind of startled by the
sudden disconnected the autopilot and
they dealt with it poorly and they
actually had no training in flying the
airplane manually at high altitudes for
most of the time it was all on autopilot
and and they'd lost trust in their
AirSpeed reading so even when they
returned to normal a few minutes later
they still didn't trust them
after climbing about 2000 feet the the
plane's AirSpeed drop reciply and a
stall warning started to blur in the
cockpit first officer Robert tried to
tell bonan that they needed to go down
and bond and agreed
um but they needed set to descend but
nevertheless kind of kept pulling back
on on the side stick at this point he'd
raised and I was up to 16 degrees
and the plane uh I wouldn't I'm sorry
woman after the control switched
um the aircraft stalled fully and
started to fall from the sky it fell
pretty much straight down now at this
point with a nose High attitude of over
40 degrees so
I'm gonna go back there
um the corrective course of action
should have been obviously the pilots
it's something they're they're trained
from the very very start and that's to
point the knowledge down gain speed and
basically fly out of the stall
um but neither officers seem to to have
any idea about what was happening and
they were completely overwhelmed with
with the emergency
um bonnen in particular seemed to
reverse that very Primal Instinct that
people have that when you're falling
down you pull the stick to pull the nose
up to go up
um Roberto meanwhile didn't really know
what Bonham was doing and Bonner never
told him um to make matters worse both
Pilots probably thought that they
couldn't stole the plane and if they'd
been in normal law that would have been
true but because things had switched
into this alternate law and the plane
and the automation couldn't actually
prevent this at all
so Captain's a boy returned to find the
cockpit in chaos and he asked what was
happening and Robert responded that
we've totally lost control of the plane
we don't understand it at all we've
tried everything
the playing them was now falling at
about 10 000 feet per minute at an
altitude or from an altitude of 35 000
feet the nose was now pointed so high
that the computer considered the
airspeed measurements to be completely
invalid
um the stall warnings and the stall
warnings stopped because of this
this possibly kind of convinced bond
that by pulling back on the stick he was
actually helping things
um and improving the situation the
pilots continue to discuss what to do
for a couple of minutes um but nobody
noticed the fact that they were actually
in a stall
finally as the plane dropped through
about ten thousand feet that's about
three thousand meters just for reference
um Roberto climb climb climb and Barnum
responded saying but I've had the stick
back the whole time
finally that the crew and the captain
understood why the plane was falling
from the sky first officer Robert
immediately took over controls without
telling bonnen and try to point the nose
of the plane down to gain speed but they
were very very quickly running out of
altitude Bonham panicked again and
retook control again without telling
Robert and started to pull back in the
stick again
with bottle number bear making kind of
uh opposite control inputs the the plane
average the two and continue to fall uh
pretty much uh um horizontal position
as the plane hurtled towards the ocean
uh the last words of the pilots were
captured on the cockpit voice reporter
Robert exclaimed damn it we're going to
crash this can't be happening bonan
asked but what's happening Dubois
answered 10 degrees of pitch a split
second later flight 447 slammed tail
first into the Atlantic Ocean oblitering
the aircraft and killing all 228
passengers and crew
because the plane went down without a
distress call in an area of the ocean
not covered by radar and it wasn't until
almost two hours later before anybody
noticed that 447 was missing for over 24
hours it seemed like the the plane had
vanished Without a Trace until the
Brazilian Air Force um spotted an oil
slick and light wreckage the following
day
finally on the 3rd of June um recovery
ships reached the areas area and
discovered their floating bodies
personal effects and the plane's
vertical stair but the stabilizer I'm
seen here
but most of the records actually lay far
beneath the Atlantic Ocean at a depth of
over 3000 meters and finding it would be
a huge huge challenge
for two whole years nobody actually knew
what had happened to flight 447 and
after three long and fruitless searches
in three different areas the team
finally located the wreckage in April
2011.
the flight data recorder and the cockpit
voice recorder were recovered from the
wreckage in May
and 104 bodies were also brought to the
service but 74 were never found 50 had
been recovered previously
and when investigators in France
successfully download the information
from the recorders what they found was
really almost kind of inconceivable that
three experienced Pilots flew a modern
passenger plane in absolutely perfect
condition into the sea
and it would be easy to blame Bonner and
some do um but flight 447 didn't crash
simply because he pulled back on the
control stick but rather because of a
convergence of kind of small failures
and deep psychological kind of
implications for the pilot
first um all three parts may have been
fatigued Captain the boy was heard on
the cockpit voice recorder saying that
he only got one hour of sleep beforehand
um second the pollens weren't
sufficiently trained in hand flying the
aircraft at high altitude that cruise
altitude and third and most critically
and the planes automation which was
meant to help make flying easier gave
the pilots an inconsistent and confusing
information
so changes have been made and you'll
probably be glad to hear to reduce the
likelihood of an accident like this
happen again and the pivot tubes on all
Airbus a330s and a340s were replaced
with a model that wouldn't ice up
um and give an accurate speeds
um like this this was actually before
anyone who knew what had happened to 447
so after it crashed but before it had
been found
and crews are also neck trained to to
better handle unreliable AirSpeed
indicators and high altitude solves
something that they hadn't been trained
in before
so today kind of any Pilot's face with
the same situation will immediately
remember the mistakes of crew the crew
of flight 447.
so what I'd really like to highlight
here that we can learn from is that that
the goal of the investigation
um that they that was made into 447 it
wasn't to a portion blame and it was to
discover what went wrong and how safety
could be improved to ensure that it
never happened again and while Bonham
was the The prominent actor in the story
you know he was a relatively Good Pilot
and put in just a surprising situation
that he hadn't been trained for and he
certainly didn't go to work that morning
intending to crash the plane and kill
himself you know 226 of the people
and we're starting to see this kind of
thinking uh become a bit more mainstream
in our industry too
um Google's SRE team have a great
write-up in their book on blameless
post-mortems um and the inspiration that
they actually took from the aviation
industry to to construct this and for
them I'm quote quoting here um a
blamelessly written postmortem assumes
that everyone involved in an incident
had good intentions and did the right
thing with the information they had if a
culture of finger pointing and shaming
individuals or teams for doing the wrong
thing prevails people will not bring
issues to life for fear of punishment
end quote
um so the recommendations made after the
crash of flight 447 highlight another
area of interest for us the automation
was a contributing factor in the crash
and the changes made
um included more training for Pilots to
be able to handle situations where
automation fails so automation is
obviously a huge factor for for Airline
safety and it's becoming the same for it
if you've read accelerate
um or their their state of the devops
report status report that's published
every year you'll know that huge
advantages to automation is giving to
high performing teams and but it's
important that the people who are
understanding are people who are using
your platforms are using this automation
understand the failure points of that
Automation and how to handle those
situations
team apologies that I've kind of
mentioned earlier on um has some really
good insights in the head of structure
platform teams to support this um if
you're not a Google or Netflix size
organization
and one of the things I was kind of
super stoked to see in the most of the
recent devops reports and was the
inclusion of psychological safety as a
factor in affecting high performance
teams and in the airline industry This
falls under what's known as human
factors so human factors is kind of the
application things like psychology and
anthropology and to the design and
operation of products and systems
and the purpose is to to attempt to kind
of reduce the likelihood of negative
outcomes by by understanding how people
and groups of people actually work
um
this layperson's introduction
um to our to to human factors training
is published by the Australian transport
safety Bureau that's available on the
web and it's a great short history of
the field and includes great references
to jump off into detail of the subject
so uh the understanding of understanding
how people think and react to things is
useful but to to kind of understand why
people act the way they do you need to
understand the nature of the the systems
that they operate in and to do that you
really need to understand the culture
which we'll talk about in my next
example
so on the morning of the 29th of October
2018 Lion Air Flight 610 operated by a
Boeing 737 Max 8 and push back from the
gate at so Carno had an international
airport in Jakarta
um Captain behave Senator was in command
of the aircraft along with first officer
harvana
and both Pilots had more than 5 000
hours of experience on the Boeing 737
aircraft
at 6 20 a.m local time Flight 610 began
its takeoff roll
even before the plane had left the
runway had they received the first
signal that something was wrong the
control column started shaking and
loudly warning them that the plane was
in danger of stalling and could crash
this is while they were still on the
ground
the captain decided to continue to take
off procedure and um started to climb
two critical sensors had registered
different readings between the pilot and
first officer instruments indicating two
different valleys for the plane's
AirSpeed and its altitude this confused
both Pilots
two minutes into the flight while still
attempting to climb the plane suddenly
dropped over 700 feet and furthering the
Pilot's confusion
the aircraft's automation had basically
forced the plane's nose down
the pilots recovered from the drop and
but noted to air traffic control that
they were having a flight control
problem and requested to return to the
airport
as they continue to climb to a safer
altitude um over the next 10 minutes
this pattern repeated itself with the
plane's automatic systems pointing the
nose down and captains are using what
are called electronic trim
um trim buttons on the on the control
column to correct it and this basically
kind of uh cause it to almost dolphin in
the space of one minute uh the captain
had to correct this more than five times
so fighting against the system that he
didn't understand Captain's major
repeatedly asked the first officer for a
checklist to handle unreliable air
speeds
as he continuously corrected the plane's
attitude harveino looked through the
manuals and checklist trying to find a
solution to the problem but to no avail
at 6 30 am the captain had to control of
Flight 610 over to the first officer for
reasons that are unclear instead of
using the electric trim buttons to
counteract the system the the first
officer tried to fight manually pulling
back on the control column with
everything that he could
at 6 32 the first officer told captains
in Asia twice that the plane was flying
down the captain responded to the second
attempt it's okay
employs 5000 feet at nearly 700
kilometers per hour straight into the
Java sea killing all 189 people on board
and it had been just over 12 minutes
from takeoff to the point of impact
Indonesia's National Search and Rescue
Agency immediately launched an operation
mobilizing thousands of people and to
recover the aircraft and the bodies of
the passengers and crew
even though the crash light was in a
shallow part of the ocean the violence
that the impact made recovery very very
difficult and the plane's flight data
recorder was recovered on the 1st of
November but the cockpit voice recorder
was not found until January the
following year it had been buried under
eight meters of sand it had hit so hard
on the 23rd of November investigators
concluded the victim identification
process of the 189 people on board 125
were identified and 64 bodies are still
on accounted for
when the max 8 revision
um to the enormously popular 737 series
which we've all flown on
um was imagined Boeing was facing a
competitive Challenge from their only
rival Airbus
the new Airbus A320 Neo used new larger
engines that reduce fuel consumption and
promised significant Savings in
operational costs
um that's the A320 on the the left hand
side of the diagram there
originally it was kind of considered
impossible because
um considered impossible to put larger
engines on the 737 and because the wings
on the 737 are lower on the the right
hand side there so the larger engines
would have actually the red dotted line
would have been close to the ground
but faced with a competitor who was
pulling away and the cost of Designing a
new airframe being prohibitively
expensive for for Boeing to do they
found another way
um what they did was they moved the
engines forward and up on the wing to
allow them to to accommodate the new
larger engines
this resulted in a plane that was um so
nearly identical to existing 737s that
that pilots on current models could fly
it without requiring expensive
retraining just like the A320 Neo
but by moving the engines up and forward
on the wing Boeing had changed the
Dynamics of flight slightly and
increasing the tendency of the plane to
to climb too steeply and induce the
stall
so since the value proposition to
Airlines mandated no new training they
decided that an automated solution was
required and Boeing quietly introduced
the maneuvering characteristics
augmentation system or mcads
in certain situations MCAS would
activate using stabilizer trim to
correct the angle of attack and bring it
back in line
unfortunately where the the sensor
failed the system would erroneously
follow the same procedure pushing the
nose down to disastrous effect
on the 10th of March 2019 five months
after the crash of Lion Air Ethiopian
Airlines flight 302 another Boeing 737
Max 8 crashed shortly after takeoff from
Addis Ababa in Ethiopia killing all 157
people on board
the final report for the crash
investigation of Ethiopian Airlines has
still not been released nearly two and a
half years later um but from an interim
report the MCAS system was implicated
once again and Boeing have since
admitted fault for the accident
shortly thereafter the entire Global
Fleet of 737 Max aircraft was grounded
pending an investigation and while
they've since returned to service they
are still grounded in some parts of the
world
for Lion Air Flight 610 the final report
was pretty damning um first it found
that the the aircraft should have been
grounded before departing on the Fatal
flight because of an earlier cockpit
issue
the day before the crash another flight
crew on the same aircraft had the exact
same system malfunctioned on a flight
from Denpasar into Jakarta and with the
help of a third Lion Air pilot who just
happened to be to be um on the flight
and in the cockpit the crew deactivated
the MCAT system and flew the plane
manually to its destination and but no
entry had been made in the maintenance
log about the issue
and the pilots on 610 didn't even know
that there were any major problems on
the previous flight
further the the report found that the
first officer had performed poorly in
training and had struggled to remember a
list of procedures that he should have
had memorized
he was flying plane um just before it
went into that fatal dive and but the
report said that the the captain hadn't
briefed him properly properly before
handing over the controls too
so there's a lot of kind of what-ifs
here um if the the crew of the previous
flight had given
um more detailed description of the
problem the aircraft might you know
never taken off that day on the Fatal
flight and if the captain who up until
that point had success successfully kind
of kept the flight in the air and if he
hadn't handed over to his less capable
first officer again the disaster might
have been avoided and there's certainly
kind of questions around the safety
culture of Lion Air
but most of the blame in the report
um was centered on Boeing and the U.S
Federal Aviation Administration or the
FAA
um it pinpointed the design and
certification of the 737 Max 8 as the
primary route of the problem
investigators uh
listed the design of the MCAT system
itself as a contributing factor because
it relied on information from a single
external sensor
and making it vulnerable to obviously
two erroneous input from that sensor
they find that Boeing was able to design
and test its own system without prior
oversight or a thorough safety
assessment from the FAA
and the Boeing Engineers never expected
that M cars would fail
um continuously and repeatedly and never
even seriously considered it as a
possibility when they were designing the
system they concluded that a repeated
failure of the of MCAS was no more
problematic than a one-time failure
because they assumed that the pilots
would simply apply the opposite trim
input and counteract the MCAT they also
seen that Pilots would immediately
recognize the problem and override the
system with manual flight controls
um and that doing so would and I quote
here um not require exceptional piloting
skills or strength however near the end
of the The Lion Air flight the first
officer was pulling back on the control
column with over 50 kilograms of force
basically nearly his entire body weight
but he was unable to keep the plane from
diving into the ground
the reporter also found that flight
Crews lacked key information about the
MCAT system they didn't even know it
existed and since none of it was
included in the training manuals or the
aircraft manuals
when Boeing originally um started
marketing the 737 Max 8 it was a
brilliant success and they overtook
Airbus in the segment with 737 Max
orders Rising 300 in 2012 and Airbus
A320 Neo orders dropping 50 and but
internal Communications handed over to
the U.S congressional investigators in
January 2020 exposed a collapse in
engineering culture and morale during
the design of the 737 Max 8.
employees who were developing the
computer-based training training for the
737 Max suggested providing more
guidance in the pilot manual on how to
handle certain emergencies and raise
concerns that the skills assumed were
not various um not very intuitive for
younger Pilots or for those who had
become accustomed and too reliant on
automation they were told that that's
probably true
um but it's the box that were painted
into and what they were being pressured
to do
sure Boeing's culture driven by market
forces and competition had foregone
safety in the words of Stan sorcer a
former Boeing engineer priorities had
shifted over the last two decades with
profit mattering more than quality
so culture is a little bit of an
overused and abused phrase in business a
lot of the times we hear Tech
organizations talking about their
culture they're talking about things
about like you know we've got pizza and
beer on a Friday night or we've got an
Xbox in the lunchroom and but that's not
culture culture is the way that a
company does things and really what's
important to them
and for us in Tech I think a failure and
culture can come in in kind of many
different ways if if you're a product
company it might be that you know you
fail to build what the customer actually
wants because you start focusing on the
most profitable features or trying to
keep your your existing market share
Steve Jobs did an interview on this it's
available on YouTube and uh on why this
happened at Xerox and how the the shift
from leadership being from product
people
um into marketing people being as
Leaders uh cause one of the most
Innovative early it companies to fail
puts it way more assisting being better
than I could
um for most it works um be they kind of
internal or external level failure of
culture might be because you're you're
dropping quality to meet deadlines like
we saw it booming there
um and I saw that this study linked on a
thread on Twitter last week
um but reflect something I've seen I
haven't had a chance to fully dig into
it but the paper was written by Margaret
Ann story from the University of
Victoria with contribution from
Microsoft and Microsoft research and
looked at um as the title says how
developers and managers Define and trade
productivity for quality and the Crux of
what they found was was interesting that
the developers think their managers just
care about outputs
um as opposed to kind of quality and
outcome
um and they think that managers would
sacrifice quality for output and whereas
managers and you can be a bit sarcastic
and say that they say but managers say
that they actually care about quality
and outcomes
so it seems like the managers and
developers have well number one they've
got different definitions of what
productivity is
um and that makes measuring productivity
effectively impossible for us
and and without like a common definition
or it's even harder to to agree like
what changes to make to A team's process
and workflows
where I've seen this in action uh is in
hearing tech people talk about the
business
and if you come across that before
you've heard it
um and usually it's in the context of oh
no no no the business wouldn't go for
that you know
um
and more often than not when I've dug
into it when I've asked them like who is
the business who's the person we need to
talk to to get approval for this they
can't tell me it's like it's not a
person it's not an apartment it's just
this kind of imagined entity demanding
or denying things you know
and my answer to people or my question
almost to people like that is to to kind
of compare to people who say I'm stuck
in a traffic jam and you're not in
traffic you are traffic and you're not
delivering to the business you are the
business you know so act like it and
make a decision and don't defer to some
imagined business
okay it's like random soapbox over
um
[Music]
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you
um
no I've completely lost where I am yeah
no no you're okay I'll just take the
Applause
um so the thing is though in terms of
culture there are no quick fixes to a
failing culture and the only thing I I
can really kind of suggest is
um if you have the will to go and to
keep going is to you know rage rage
against the dying of the light to try
and keep that culture
to learn more about building great
cultures and companies I'd highly
recommend good to Great by Jim Collins
and there's heaps of books out there
about culture this one talks about the
kind of underlying variables of what it
is that actually makes a great company
and it backs it up with real data as
opposed to the kind of survivorship by
SEC and only the some of the other kind
of great culture books which is yeah it
was great for Spotify in 1997 in a small
suburb in Sweden
[Music]
um Collins also talks about building a
culture of discipline which I I think is
a better generic term for it um I've
used the kind of a culture of quality
before but as we see in quality is a bit
of a fluffy term
um I think discipline kind of captures
better um as a concept and be that like
a discipline of safety or uh like a
discipline of engineering quality
and if you work in a bureaucratic
organization and where any kind of
cultural change is unimaginable
um have a read of the delicate art of
bureaucracy for some ideas that was
recommended to me last year it is a
great read and um
not as dry as you think for a book about
bureaucracy
so um for buying their change of culture
had disastrous effects
um not only in lives but also as a
business they lost 80 billion in fines
and canceled orders and it remains to be
seen how they'll come out of this crisis
especially after covert 19. and Netflix
have released a documentary on Boeing
called danfall and it's well worth a
watch if you'd like to learn more
um it is pretty shocking some of some of
the stuff that went on there
but the airline industry in general is
built on a culture of safety and there's
no way that they could do what they do
at the scale that they do without it and
one of the key mechanisms that they they
use to achieve this is actually
understanding risk
so every component on an aircraft has a
well understood fader rate and
appropriate maintenance or replacement
rate to ensure that they don't get to
that point
for this last example um I want to talk
about something a little bit closer to
home
um both geographically and
professionally to highlight why
understanding risk is important
yes Qantas
um
so Qantas flight 72 was and still is a
regularly scheduled service between
Singapore and Perth Western Australia
where I live and I've been on this
um did someone just woo that yeah cool
um
on the 7th of October 2008 it was
operated by a wide body Airbus A330
again a330s are very safe though I've
just realized there's two of them in
here
um the flight left Singapore at 9 32
local time with 303 passengers and 12
crew aboard heading south across the
Indian Ocean
in command of the flight was Captain
Kevin Sullivan and first officer Peter
lipsett and both of whom had more than
10 10 000 hours flying a third pilot
Second Officer Ross Hales was also
flying along so that the pilots could
alternate rest breaks during the flight
about halfway through the Journey um the
first officer lets it gave up his seat
to to uh to hail
um to go on his rest break it was 12 39
pm
deep in the a330s avionics Bay a fault
appeared in a device called the air data
inertial reference unit or adiru1 for
short and I'm just going to refer to it
the iru because adiru is very hard to
say hard it's like multiple times
um the A330 has three irus Each of which
is connected to an independent set of
sensors and and they measure a wide
range of parameters from things like the
the airspeed and the altitude the and
the angle of attack so that's the kind
of the measure of the pitch angle of the
plane relative to the airflow so that
kind of angle there
the irus that process or they process
that information and they feed it into
the fly computers
um and they do this in the form of
32-bit words encoded in binary
some of you may already know what's
coming on this one
um so a word from the IOU uh sent the
flight computer contains an 8-bit label
that signifies what type of information
is being conveyed so that might be um
AirSpeed altitude or angle of attack it
also has a two-bit Source destination
identifier up to 19 bits of actual kind
of measured data and a two-bit status
indicator that signifies whether it's
valid or invalid and also a one bit
parody indicator as well it's great that
I don't have to explain this to you
would have taken to his son
um our particular interest to us though
is that 19-bit data section
so each bit in the 19-bit sequence is
assigned a particular number because uh
and that number is always twice the
preceding number
and that changes based on the kind of
parameters so what it actually gets
mapped to back in it and the value is
encoded as the sum of those numbers so
for example for flight 72's cruising
altitude of 37 000 and 12 feet and which
is on the the right hand side of the the
red box there so you can read it from
the back and that's indicated by a
binary value of one on bits 27 24 19 and
15.
um
with all the other bits set to zero so
what exactly happened inside the iou1 on
flight 72 at precisely 1240 is still
unknown to this day but as soon as the
error occurred and the iru started to
send out bursts of mislabel data where
altitude information was mislabeled as
angle of attack information
um because the exact value of the data
encoded in the words depends on what
type of data is labeled as that
information obviously became corrupted
so if we take that previous example of
37 012 feet on the scale used for angle
of attack data which is in the red box
on the left hand side though those exact
same bits correspond to the values
summing to a total of 50.625 degrees
so basically what the data is saying
here is that the plane is pointing like
this as opposed to what it actually is
pointing like this
so the built-in error correction and
that labeled the data is valid or
invalid didn't catch the problem because
the corruption occurred during the word
assembly process after the checks have
been performed
in the cockpit though the pilots noticed
the bad effects of the data within
seconds of its creation first the
autopilot disconnected as it was unable
to reconcile the difference between the
three ru's and Captain Sullivan
immediately announced that he had manual
control
um less than five seconds later the
pilots found themselves bombarded by a
sudden Cascade of warnings and fault
messages flooded onto the computer
screen in the central console and the
stall and overspeed warnings both
started going off intermittently now
this is pretty much impossible because
the style means you're going too slow
and an over speed means you're going too
fast
so Captain Sullivan tried to engage the
A330 second backup autopilot and at the
same time
the airspeed and altitude values on his
flight display which are sourced from
ireu1 just went haywire fluctuating
completely wildly compared to the you
know just the plane cruising along
in response to the unreliable AirSpeed
indications Sullivan Switched Off the
autopilot and flew the plane manually
um using the standby instruments on the
co-pilot side
and oddly baffled by the Cascade of
warnings Captain Sullivan and Second
Officer Hales called first officer lift
it back to the cockpit to try and help
figure out what was going on but before
Alexa could make it back um what had
just been happening in the computer up
until now suddenly broke through into
the real world
a spike of altitude data which are going
to be mislabeled as angle of attack data
and marked as valid by the flight
computer and triggered the plane's
automated protections so these
protections normally prevent pilots from
making control inputs that could put the
plane into danger and but in this case
it applied a certain 10 degree nose down
elevator movement and the fact that this
command while in Cruise flight was
sudden and catastrophic the plane
entered an immediate dive
in the carpet the pilots were pulled up
and out of their seats restrained only
by their lap belts
um but in the back at least 60
passengers weren't wearing their um
weren't wearing their seat belts and the
negative g-forces slammed them head
first into the bottom of the overhead
bins
most of the crew and around 20
passengers were out of their seats
carrying out their duties or going to
the toilet
um and they were thrown against the
ceiling with massive Force
um luggage compartments burst open
spilling suitcases and backpacks into
the aisles and drinks food laptops books
everything they tell you about and other
loose items flew in every direction
back in the cockpit Captain Sullivan
reached for the side stick to pull the
aircraft out of the dive but when he
tried to bring the nose up there was no
response the automatic systems had
locked them out so we let go and try it
again and this time because the data
Spike was over the elevators responded
and he was able to bring the plane out
of the dive
as the negative G-Force is subsided
though everyone in the cabin who had
been pinned to the ceiling now came
crashing back down hitting the floor
seats and other passengers
and amongst the passengers themselves
there were broken bones concussions
serious lacerations and more
all of the flight attendants were
injured to to various degrees and one
person broke a leg several suffered
serious spinal injuries and many were
bleeding profusely and first officer
Lipson who'd been making his way back to
the cockpit actually broke his nose
I'm now back in control though Solomon
and Hayes who were not hurt and we're
trying to clear all of these error
messages from the computer screen and
get the flight back on on track
as they worked and the stall and
overspeed warnings continue to blur
um Second Officer Hale made an
announcement over the public addresses
some calling for all past news and crew
to sit down and fasten their seat belts
immediately
yeah
um suddenly another Spike bad Spike
though of AOA data made it through to
the fly computer this time the dive
wasn't as Steep and most of the people
had fasten their seat belts but for the
people who were injured or the people
helping them
um they were thrown into the ceiling
again
this time just like the first time
Solomon's initial efforts to pull back
up
um had no effect but the resistance
stopped after a few seconds and he was
able to level the plane out
so with all kinds of alarms going on and
off in the background and new error
messages kind of constantly popping up
and the crew were unsure of what was
happening and feared that they could go
into a dive again at any moment so they
decided to declare a Mayday and diverted
for an emergency landing to lermoth in
or near exmouth and wa
at this time um Sullivan noted that the
automated strip uh trim stabilizer and
wasn't working and that trim would
actually have to be adjusted manually so
this is using like a wheel to do it and
the navigation equipment was also not
functioning and they couldn't interact
with the computer interface at all
and so the pilots flew the remainder of
the flight on full manual mode trying to
ignore the constant spurious alarms that
refused to turn off
the sun pitch stands never returned and
flight 72 landed safely at learmonth at
1 32 pm
all told 119 of the 315 passengers and
crew were injured 12 of them seriously
and the interior of the carbon was was
utterly trashed and while the plane
would fly again and no one was killed
and many people suffered injuries that
will be with them for the rest of their
lives
so investigation investigators with the
Australian Transportation safety board
um had to ask how could something like
this happened
how's it turned out though um this
wasn't the first time this type of error
had occurred
another Qantas A330 had experienced a
similar data problem in 2006. also off
the coast of Western Australia and in
December of 2008 after this accident had
occurred um it happened again on another
Qantas flight
also off the coast of Western Australia
um luckily neither of these two other
cases involved an uncommander pitch down
and but the failure mode for the iru in
all three instances was similar and two
of them even involved the exact same ru
so the fact that these failures had all
occurred within a small geographical
region um
seemed you know kind of too strange to
be a coincidence but despite a variety
of theories and a call from the
Australian and the international Pilots
Association to ban flight over the area
totally and investigators couldn't
really find anything inherent to Western
Australia that could have caused
malfunctions
and there were suggestions that the
Harold Holt's Naval communication
station if you've ever been to exmouth
you'll have seen this and that this
might have caused the issue but the the
testing on the unit on the actual unit
itself they submitted to lower level
radiation or radio frequencies and
proved this to be highly unlikely
um in fact the the atsb was never able
to conclusively find what caused the IOU
malfunction and
uh what what caused the center to
mislabel data and the only theory that
they couldn't rule out 100 was what's
called a single event effect or an SE
for short and an SE occurs when a high
energy particle from outer space like a
cosmic ray or a neutrino and to be a
neutron to be more exact and strikes a
chip and it randomly flips a bit from a
one to a zero or a zero to a one so the
theory is that if an SE occurred at a
critical location within the iru's GPU
memory module or cpu's memory module and
it could just maybe have triggered
everything that kind of followed on from
there
but what made the failure of the IOU
dangerous um was not that it failed per
se um but that the
um invalid data passed through so many
layers of cross-checks that they'd had
that were in place without being flagged
as invalid
so the investigative fan that a
previously kind of unknown failure mode
in which data spikes occurring at
approximately 1.2 seconds could trick
the computer into thinking that the data
was valid and this was where the real
kind of safety problem lay you know it
might not be possible to stop a few ones
and zeros from becoming corrupted every
now and then then but if the layer
protections that are in place couldn't
identify that corrupted data that
represented what the real security risk
was
but the protections that were in place
on the um IOU itself and were pretty
good they could weed out 93.5 of invalid
data on its own with its own checks
before even passing it to the computer
which did its own cross-checking again
and obviously this wasn't enough to
prevent the industry injury of like 119
people and but in principle the iru
remained completely safe
and this type of failure only occurred
three times in 128 million hours of
service for this module
um well within the probability zone of
what Regulators can consider to be
extremely remote
and it's final report him the HSB wrote
that the investigation was extremely
difficult and touched on numerous areas
where no accident investigation had
ventured before the authors of the
report were also keenly aware that that
Qantas flight 72 incident um could be
representative of the sort of case that
would become more common in the modern
automated era
um just days after the accident Airbus
issued a bulletin to all A330 operators
instructing pilots who immediately shut
off the indicated IOU when receiving a
fault and this advice might have
actually been what what um what prevent
a similar accident in the Qantas Flight
later in December of that year
um those parts in on that flight 71 they
experience the same thing but turns off
within about 28 seconds
and Airbus also redesigned the logic
keys by the flight computer to verify
angle of attack data and removing the
possibility that a well-timed spike like
that could cause the same kind of
incident again
um furthermore airbrush has also
introduced novel ways of testing its
data verification software including
testing with intermittent data spikes
which had not previously been attempted
um so safety agencies are are still
researching the best ways to approach
this kind of problem and our
understanding of the safety implications
of it are still developing
nevertheless though I think Qantas
flight 72 stands out as the the first
case where investigators delve deeply
into a software failure and um hopefully
uh serves as a reminder of the
importance of keeping your seatbelt
fastened at all times
awesome so there's a lot obviously I
think we could take out of this in that
it was a kind of a software problem
um but what I really want to highlight
is how risk and the understanding of
risk allows commercial airlines to
operate in at the safety kind of
standards that they do and it's
something that we're definitely getting
better at as an industry particularly
you know kind of larger companies who
can afford to invest into that
um but it's something like that I rarely
see discussed at the at in Enterprise IT
projects and there's actually quite a
lot of data and Analysis out there that
can help us to do this
so in general and project performance
has been improving globally in 2021 and
nearly 70 of projects met their original
goals or business intent while 60 were
completed within the original budget and
but it projects as we all know are in
inherently are notoriously difficult to
manage
um a survey published by the Harvard
Business Review found that the average
IT project over on its budget by 27 and
moreover at least one in six IT projects
turns into a Black Swan where where the
cost to overrun of at least 200 and a
schedule overrun of 70 percent
and failure rate corresponds heavily to
the project size so a project with a
budget of over one million dollars is 50
more likely to fail than a project with
a budget of under three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
uh PWC study of over 10 000 projects
found that only 2.5 percent of companies
complete their project 100 successfully
and I'd argue that those two point five
percent are liars
um
overall these failures cost between 50
to 150 billion of lost revenue and
productivity every year
last one 17 of IT projects can go so bad
that they can threaten the very
existence of a company but I've never
heard anyone or any project even
consider that as a remote possibility
for what they're doing is what we're
building something that could destroy
our whole company
but it should be
so one thing I hear a lot from people
and when I bring this up is that it's
hard or it's impossible to quantify
certain types of risk um and that's not
true if you can kind of if you
understand something you can model it
and even if that just means that you can
put a realistic range on it that's a
much better answer than I don't know
what it is and there's a whole bunch of
tools out there that can help you so if
you want to measure anything there is a
very useful book called how to measure
anything and it'll help you measure
intangible things like the cost of
security breaches or brand damage and a
mistake that I see a lot of people
making is when they start to look at
risk is that they use averages and
um obviously it's not great for
understanding risk and you should really
be using things like sampling ranges and
models to assess these things instead
and the flaw of averages explains this
complex area really well and it's a
great layperson's introduction to
statistics and risk it helped me to
understand it
um and the work of trime against and
focused objectives in Seattle
um they provide free to use spreadsheets
to help you get started with this in
your software development project and
specifically and Troy is originally from
Australia um and he runs awesome
training courses when he comes back
every now and again so if you do get the
chance to go I'd highly recommend it
sign up for his newsletter too
um so what I hope you kind of take from
this is all of this really is that the
rules and regulations for for Airline
safety are unfortunately Written in
Blood and for most of us we don't have
that same pressure I think ours are
written in either our own sweat or in
the frustrated kind of tiers of our
users and but as a profession you know
we can look to what others have done and
apply what they've learned the hard way
to make our customers and our own lives
better
so that's all I've got for you today um
I hope you've learned something that you
can take back from your teams and maybe
feel a little bit safer about flying
nope
um if you're Keen to read more about air
crashes um I'll post a link in the
conference like to to this and all my
other resources
um but the work of Admiral cloudberg who
does ride-ups on air crashes they are
absolutely amazing and they're the
source of the the stories that I've told
you today
um or just hit me up there's my contact
details on the bottom but um that's it
um thank you for your time enjoy the
last day of the conference
and safe travels cheers